5 55 on your monday morning a school  zone reminder from a concerned viewer or  a week into the new school year and  viewer donnie he's already fed up he  writes i have no problem slowing down  for kids they're unpredictable but he  writes the parents are quite possibly  the worst drivers in the world double  parked illegal u-turns constant  near-misses of fender benders from not  checking blind spots just pulling the  cars off parents don't pay attention  rant over okay parents  pay attention double parking and u-turns  are illegal in school zones thanks for  writing in donnie buckle up drive  carefully please put down that phone  something's driving you crazy email me  traffic 8 8newsnow.com